♪ (jazzy theme music)
I invited friends to
play some games in a pub.
No big prizes for the winner,
just bragging rights and
a plug for their channel
at the end of the video.
Joining me are science broadcaster
and poker champion Liv Boeree,
cardiologist Rohin Francis
from Medlife Crisis,
and crossword and sudoku
expert Mark Goodliffe
from Cracking the Cryptic.
Liv, Rohin, Mark.
Thank you very much for joining
me in the back of the pub.
The game is Skull and
here's how it's played.
Each player has four cards:
three flowers and one skull.
To start, everyone
plays one card face down
and then each player in turn has a choice:
play another card or start the bidding.
Once someone bids, no
more cards are played.
Each player can either up the bid
or pass and sit out of the round.
Whoever gives the highest
bid then has to turn over
that many flowers without
revealing a single skull.
And they have to turn over
all their own cards first.
Succeed and they win a point,
but if they turn over a skull,
no points and they lose one random card.
Lose all your cards and you're out.
First to two points wins the game.
If we're all ready, we all put
down one card to start off.
And you're to my right.
You can either play a card
or you can start the bidding.
I play a card.
A lot of cards are on the table now.
Let's keep it going.
So to start the bidding I...
Just say a number.
Say a number.
Five.
Ah, that's a really good bid. (laughs)
I would absolutely have bid five.
No, you know what?
I'm going to pass.
I'm going to let you two
argue this out. Pass.
Six.
Aggressive.
How many cards have we got?
There's two down here.
So it's three there.
It's three there— Oh, damn it.
I should totally have bid six.
Pass.
Nine cards.
It's not enough information to go on.
Not on the first round.
Pass.
All right, that's three passes.
Six is the bid.
One, two, three.
(sighs)
I'll have the first of Liv's. Four.
The first of Tom's.
That's five.
Five.
(sighs)
And Liv's.
Six.
Whoa.
Nice.
Very good play.
I want to see what you had.
(group laughing)
For the benefit of the audience,
can we all turn away
and Rohin can show
what he had to the camera.
Oh the handy mirror.
Yeah, don't look in the mirror.
(laughs)
There we go.
I'm also, if you would turn
away, going to just show that.
There we go. Thank you.
Right. So, you flip your
mat on the very first one.
Ah.
Phew, this could be
a short game, folks.
This could be short. Right.
Card down, please.
And it is your move.
Okay, I will put a card down.
Three.
So, silly question, I can't
add another card now?
You can't add another card now.
Okay.
And there's only five on the table.
Hmm. Nice play.
Three. Pass.
I was really hoping
you weren't going to bet.
(group laughing)
I am convinced that
every one of you sods
has put a skull down, so
I am not going to bid.
I'm going to pass as well.
I think you've put a skull down
and you're trying to bait me
into four.
Wow.
Pass.
He's called everyone
as putting a skull down.
Mhm.
Well, I'm passing.
That's a skull. That's
totally— (sighs)
Wrong there.
But now where do I go?
Now you have to pick two more.
Tom.
Two.
(group sighs)
Well done.
Nice.
I was so sure that was a skull.
The way you've put it down.
Yeah, I was sure.
For the benefit of the audience,
we're going to look away.
Liv, could you show the camera?
And we're all going to look away.
Mark, if you could show the camera.
Thank you.
I'm looking forward to
seeing what those were,
'cause I was convinced that...
Ah, okay, fine.
Well this is a dangerous position.
No one's even lost a card yet.
Is it on?
So we all put one in.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
It's on you.
Three.
Four.
Oh, I'm not doing five.
There's no way I'm doing that, no.
There's landmines all round here.
There's eight cards down,
but I'm still going to pass.
I'll pass.
Right.
Your own first.
Wait, I have to do my own first?
Yeah.
(bleep)
(group laughing)
We did say that several
times. That has...
Okay.
Ah, that's—
Did not realise that.
To to be fair,
yeah, you...
I'm screwed then.
And here.
Oh wow.
Wow, wow, my god!
[group laughing]
See I told you, poker
skills, bluffing skills...
Own first didn't matter there.
Okay, there was no way
you could've won that one.
Technically you knocked
yourself out there,
so one of us takes a card
at random from your pile.
Ideally, you don't want to lose the skull.
We'll see how it goes.
I'll take that one.
If that was a card force,
it was done very well.
Lovely, all right.
So I need to turn this over?
No, no.
No.
Oh no, I stay like this.
Stay like this.
All right, next round.
And Liv, it is you to start.
So one card down by default
and now your first move,
another card or a bid.
Three.
Four.
That was a bad bid and
I answered too quickly.
Yeah.
So fast!
Damn it.
I know,
but with you I'm never sure
if it's a double bluff.
- Yeah, but then he says this,
so now why would he feign...?
Five.
Ooh.
What I should have bid.
I would happily have bid five.
I was going to go for five,
but don't know if I can do a six.
Six.
Pass.
Seven.
Ooh!
Pass.
I've got two.
I don't think you'd make
the same mistake twice,
or it's the best bluff
ever, so let's see yours.
There we go.
Four.
Top one of both of yours,
please. Rohin first.
(sighs) One of those is a skull.
I'm sure one of those is a skull.
How would it work, that
you know that one is a skull?
Oh, sorry, let me re-phrase that.
At least one of those is a skull!
Okay.
You passed very early.
Rohin, the other one.
Yes!
Wow.
Turn away, and I'll show the camera
my last one.
For the benefit of the count
and the audience.
We'll see how that— Thank you.
Right.
Point to you, Tom.
(sighs, laughs)
I knew the minute I said four,
"Oh, I can get more
than that out of here,"
and I just instinctively...
I was sure you were going
to go for seven on that.
But, all right.
Did vaguely consider eight.
(laughs)
Only you know if that
would have been a good bid.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
So one card down.
I'll go.
And it's on me.
Ha, I'm tempted to immediately go three,
just to be a jackass,
but no, I'll play.
I'll play.
Three.
Logically, I need to bid four,
unless...
No, just 'cause I think that's a skull.
No, no, pass.
Why would you think
that's a skull, though?
'Cause that I'm the first
one to turn the thing over,
so it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, I know.
I think you're trying to bait
me into bidding too high.
You just bid three. He's
he's using that information.
If you were bidding four—
What's wrong with bidding three?
If you were bidding four or five—
It's low enough that
someone else is going to bid
on-top of you, so you're
safe from going first
kind of thing.
Right, right, right.
I just don't want to lose.
That's fair. I'm still
passing, I'm still passing.
Someone else can take that.
So you're passing three?
I'm passing three.
I'm going to pass.
Four.
(sighs)
If he's right, he wins.
And if he gets—
Five.
I'm already out,
I can't come back in.
No, I'm out.
Okay, I'm not going to say anything.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
He's not going to reveal his thoughts.
Oh, he is. Here we go.
Going to...
So what was the bid, sorry?
Five.
It was on five.
I'm going to say six.
There are only seven cards
on the table.
Well I pass.
Okay.
All right.
Your own first.
Yeah.
(group laughs)
The confidence! The outright—
You bluffed yourself!
Yeah, no, I actually
put the wrong card down.
That's unlucky.
Ohh, right.
So, for the benefit of the audience, Liv.
That's what Liv had.
I'm going to put mine up now,
if you'll all close your eyes.
I'm 90% sure your bottom
card was a skull, Tom.
All right. He says
bottom card was a skull.
And I'll turn away as well.
Audience can see those cards.
And that's all done, thank you.
Ah, that's embarrassing, isn't it?
That's funny.
I was trying to be all casual, you know,
taking it without looking, but
I clearly took the wrong one.
(Tom and Liv laugh)
Sorry I just... Or either that—
Self bluffing is the best.
Well yes, or either that, or that's
some complicated triple bluff.
Shall I take one out?
And he was hoping
to get you to yourself.
Or that, yeah.
Right, okay, okay.
Card down,
and it is Rohin to go first.
Four.
Pass.
Five.
There's six on the table, right?
Mm-hmm.
Pass.
One of you two has a skull. I'm not...
So, Rohin.
Select your five.
Okay.
Let's see. The jeopardy!
It's not going to be
the skull this time.
One, two.
Tom?
No, mate!
(sighs)
(laughs)
Complete lie.
I knew you were overly
performative about it.
I nearly blew it.
Yeah.
When you went, "Fff,"
I nearly went, "Eee."
I think you'll see my face twitch there.
For the camera, Mark,
if you show what you had...
I'll show mine.
There we go.
And Liv, if you could show what you had.
All right. (sighs)
So, I take one of those
and he's down to two.
Good news is, if I just took his skull,
his decision is going to be a lot easier.
So, right. Okay.
And it is Rohin to go now.
Argh.
Four.
Of course, he has to.
He hasn't got a card.
He's got to bid.
Well, unless he's bluffing.
Oh, I see, he hasn't got
a card to play. I see.
Yeah.
Thank you for telling me that.
That's a good point.
Yeah, he hasn't got a
card to play. He had to bid.
And if there's a skull in there,
he's got to turn his own over first.
Five.
Got to check what I... (sighs)
Six.
Hah, hah.
If you go to eight now, I swear...
That's not one of the
options I'm considering.
Seven.
Damn.
Well, I've already made a
bit of an arse of myself
in this game, so let's go
out in a blaze of glory
and say eight.
Oh, brave man.
So there are only
eight cards on the table.
If none of us played a skull,
you've won the game.
Oh yes, okay. Well that's
a high risk strategy.
If, however, any of these are skulls,
then you're down to one card.
Let's see yours first.
Pick your order.
Let's go anticlockwise.
Looking good so far.
Ohh, but I think...
(group cheers)
Redemption.
Wow.
Amazing.
Well played.
Rohin, 20 seconds down the
lens, give us the end card.
♪ (jazzy theme music)
Hi everyone, I am Rohin.
I'm a cardiologist, but
I've got a YouTube channel
where I just kind of talk
nonsense about medicine.
My videos are pretty useless
on the whole...
and kind of more puns than actual science.
And it's just kind of (bleep)-posting
made into video form.
Liv, Rohin, Mark, thank you so much!
[Formatting: Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]